merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues mon
premier mot s'adresse aux ukrainiennes
et aux Ukrainiens attaqué blessé violet
et tué le 24 février dernier Vladimir
Poutine et son gouvernement ont décidé
seuls et délibérément de violer la
Charte des Nations Unies et d'attaquer
un pays libre et souverain
désormais il prétend d'un excès de force
au dépend entier de l'Ukraine nous le
disons ici clairement nous ne
reconnaîtrons jamais les résultats des
référendums d'annexion de quatre régions
ukrainiennes
c'est pour moi purement et simplement un
national
de l'idée de nation
depuis le début le peuple ukrainien se
bat courausement pour son intégrité sa
liberté et son identité dans ce combat
ce n'est pas seulement leur terre qu'ils
défendent ce sont nos valeurs celle de
l'Union européenne de paix de liberté et
du droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux-mêmes ce sont ces valeurs que le
régime de Poutine veut réprimer
mais contrairement à 2014 contrairement
à l'annexion de la Crimée l'Union
européenne a su répondre de façon forte
et unanime face à l'agression prémédité
de la Russie
sous la présidence française de l'Union
européenne nous avons adopté un paquet
de sanctions économiques politique et
financière d'une ampleur inédite notre
président a supporté l'idée de
l'autonomie stratégique européenne nous
avons exprimé sans ambiguïté notre
soutien à l'Ukraine et soutenu son
effort de guerre par des mesures
économiques et des livraisons militaires
conséquentes nous avons accueilli vous
l'avez souligné madame la Première
ministre de manière solidaire en
cohérence avec nos valeurs et dans le
respect de la convention de Genève les
réfugiés de guerre Ukrainiens affirmons
le cette solidarité avec le peuple
ukrainien c'est l'honneur de la France
nous refusons nous refusons de croiser
les bras devant l'impérialisme russe
désormais certains et nous les entendons
jusque dans cette émission appel à
remettre en cause ses sanctions affirme
qu'elle serait inutile et voudrait ainsi
que l'invasion d'un État souverain et la
mort de milliers de personnes restent
sans conséquence
en sanctionnant la Russie nous
affaiblissons son économie et donc son
effort de guerre le PIB russe est ainsi
d'ores et déjà en récession et la Russie
ne peut plus importer de technologie
pour ces industries ou emprunter sur les
marchés à ceux qui se font le relais de
sa propagande je pose donc la question
si ces sanctions étaient si inefficaces
pourquoi Poutine chercherait-il
désespérément à les faire lever
oui certains ici jouent avec les peurs
de nos concitoyens ils trouvent alors
des solutions toutes faites considèrent
que la crise que nous vivons serait la
responsabilité de la France et de
l'Europe parce qu'elles ont choisi de
défendre la liberté du peuple ukrainien
et donc nos valeurs la Russie nous
combat sans pudeur en déployant sa
propagande dans les médias et sur les
réseaux sociaux en planifiant des
cyberattaques sur nos installations en
s'attaquant à notre sécurité alimentaire
au prix de l'énergie à la sécurité
nucléaire et c'est donc nous qui serions
les coupables à celles et ceux qui
accament sans cesse l'Union européenne
envoyé plutôt vos doléances au Kremlin
par les directement à vos créanciers
les fesses sont là les fesses sont
documentées illustrées précis
incontestable c'est en Ukraine que les
villes se font détruire à coup de
mortiers Mario Paul en est le triste
symbole c'est en Ukraine que défaire le
des soldats russes avez-vous vu des
troupes ukrainiennes en Russie c'est en
territoire ukrainien que sont dénoncés
chaque jour des exactions de l'armée
russe allant de l'exécution sommaire au
viol ou à la torture et c'est un
territoire ukrainien que l'on déterre
dans des chartiers des dizaines de corps
humain
remettre en cause l'existence de ces
crimes c'est du négationnisme les
autorités russes auront à répondre tôt
ou tard de ces crimes de guerre
il n'y a pas si longtemps encore d'une
extrême part à l'autre de cette émission
on entendait vanter le modèle politique
russe quel modèle que celui où la
population est embrigadée de force pour
une guerre à laquelle elle s'oppose quel
modèle que celui qui organise des
référendums fantoche pour annexer des
terres et des peuples contre leur gré
quel modèle que celui qui emprisonne qui
réprime qui élimine toute forme de
protestation
quelle parodie de démocratie c'est
peut-être votre modèle mais ce n'est
certainement pas le nôtre
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez continuer à fermer les yeux
et vous boucher les oreilles mais si les
Français ne sont pas en guerre sauf
conflit nous touche dans notre économie
et notre quotidien et pour ceux qui dans
cette émission disent que nous ne
protégeons pas les français des impacts
économiques de la guerre je vous pose la
question qui prolonge les tarifs
réglementés de l'électricité pas vous
qui a versé à des millions de ménages un
chèque énergie pas vous qui a voté la
loi pour la protection du pouvoir
d'achat pas vous alors oui la guerre a
des conséquences mais notre majorité et
le gouvernement sont mobilisés depuis le
début pour y répondre et continueront à
le faire aussi longtemps que nécessaire
nous le disons
nous le disons haut et fort nous ne
céderons jamais ni au chantage ni à la
menace de Poutine et pour ceux qui
continuent encore et toujours de se
gargariser devant son régime je les
invite à se rappeler du premier mot de
notre devise nationale car oui mesdames
et messieurs les députés la liberté
n'est pas en 20 mots que son contente
d'invoquer dans les meetings c'est un
principe à faire vivre et qu'il faut
défendre quand il est en péril c'est
tout le sens du soutien que la France
apporte à l'Ukraine et à son peuple
depuis le 1er jour de la guerre un
soutien sur lequel notre groupe n'a
jamais eu et n'aura jamais la moindre
ambiguïté je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]